as the kovid kovid 19 excuse me vaccine
rollout continues in nevada
one major concern for state leaders is
equity that is because certain groups
are not getting enough shots
orco mana explaining how health
advocates are tackling this issue
we need to do a little bit better health
advocates want to enhance equity in
clark county's distribution of the coven
19 vaccine the latest numbers from the
southern nevada health district show 41
percent of vaccines have been given to
white residents
while only 10 percent have been given to
hispanics and 6 percent to african
americans
we have been working on developing a
task force erica marquez with the nevada
minority health and equity coalition is
trying to make a difference she says
certain minority groups aren't getting
enough vaccines
partially because of vaccine hesitancy
and a lack of information
we are going to be looking at you know
kind of those really important
components about the communication
pieces like how are we disseminating
information into the community that's
why they're releasing these videos and
hosting webinars but there are also
barriers with making appointments since
not everyone has access to technology
it can't be solely just on an electronic
means
governor steve sislak recently announced
a vaccine equity initiative
because health district data also shows
the zip codes in clark county
with the highest number of covet 19
cases have some of the lowest frequency
of vaccinations
that makes no sense these zip codes
represent southern nevada's working
class families
lower income households the state is
working to expand outreach to those
groups and marquez is ready to help
we're
excited to kind of work hand in hand
with the governor orco mana 8 news now